welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer a memorable
jury selection continues in Wisconsin as
defendant and self-proclaimed Sovereign
citizen Daryl Brooks is ordered to leave
the courtroom even before potential
jurors are LED inside Brooks faces 77
charges including six counts of homicide
by vehicle relating to the deadly
Waukesha parade Massacre prosecutors Say
Brooks rammed his SUV into the annual
holiday parade last November killing six
and wounding dozens more jury selection
in Brooks's trial began on Monday just
days after presiding judge Jennifer
Darrow ruled Brooks could represent
himself throughout Court proceedings
Brooks has maintained he is a sovereign
citizen who does not recognize the name
Daryl Brooks on day two of jury
selection Brooks was removed from the
courtroom even before potential jurors
were brought inside after interrupting
the judge multiple times
he raises these issues really just by
simple statements he has never filed an
appropriate motion motions are governed
by state law
written motions require that the
specific relief be requested that the
motion be
based on Law and fact I've never gotten
anything even close to that from Mr
Brooks
even if I were to accept an oral motion
which can be proper at times he has
failed to follow the simplest of
procedural requirements he continues to
be in the other courtroom you can see on
the monitor he's standing he's facing
the other direction he's yelling what I
can't hear him but it appears that he is
yelling I muted him because of his
interruptions of the court and I
understand he objects his objection is
again once is noted
joining us today is legal analyst
Christian Ramey and co-host Terry Austin
Krista at first glance the most unusual
part of this case is the number of
charges but now is the defendant acting
as his own attorney going pro se so to
speak is there any possible way this
could go in his favor
yeah short answer no I mean quite
honestly I you know in my experience
jurors appreciate uh courtroom decorum
and deportment they expect attorneys to
be prepared and let against to be so as
well and so when you have a litigan a
prostate litigant like they can't even
keep it together there is no way that
that you know Works in his favor I think
that what it does is it puts people off
and we've seen this before on televised
trials where defendants go Rogue and
defend themselves I don't think this
could possibly go well for him yeah this
is not the factual case where you want
to appear like you're going rogue when
you're charged with driving through a
Christmas parade now Terry if the judge
doesn't revoke Brooks's right to
represent himself and he continues to
make a scene in court what can we expect
of the rest of this week's long trial
you know if judge Darrell does not
revoke the right to represent himself we
are in for a very challenging trial no
question he's already an unpredictable
person in general but now he is
asserting his rights as a sovereign
citizen which means he abides by some
rules and essentially he ignores other
rules and not to mention he doesn't know
the law he doesn't understand the
process and the judge has already
informed him that he is not going to
receive assistance of counsel so he is
literally left out on his own and the
judge is in a very difficult position
it's a no win for her if she didn't
allow him to do this this could have
been problematic and now she could get a
mistrial or it could be reversed on
appeal so she's going to have to figure
out a way to put this case forward I do
not envy the judge in this case well
continuing on in Celebrity legal news
we're hearing from the women behind
Johnny Depp's Victory months after a
Virginia jury largely cited with the
fame actor in a defamation suit covered
across the world lawn crime networks sat
down with Camille Vasquez and Jessica
Myers who explained how their client's
role was vital to his win
he was under a tremendous amount of
pressure especially the first week he
was nervous as we all were but I think
after opening statements after we
started the case in Chief right after we
put on the first Witnesses I think that
he started trusting in the process a bit
more and becoming more confident in what
we were doing together all together and
um
yes I I noticed that as well his mood
definitely lightened and and I think he
you know really enjoyed collaborating
with us and and he was a key
collaborator I mean every break every
lunch when we would come back from Court
every day we would see him we would go
through the day we would talk about the
next day we would get his perspectives
we would you know and he he does have an
amazing ability to recall details from
years past and so you know his insight
into this trial was
fundamental I mean we couldn't have done
it without him
and in California the sentencing for a
theranos founder and CEO Elizabeth
Holmes is delayed again so a judge can
consider if there was misconduct among
Federal prosecutors involving a star
witness during her trial in January
Holmes was found guilty of 4 out of 11
counts of defrauding investors would
stand for her touting theranos as having
breakthrough technology in blood testing
but investigators say it was all a lie
one of the government's key Witnesses
was a former theranos lab director Dr
Adam rosendorf last month rosendorff
reportedly showed up at Holmes's house
and spoke with her partner expressing
regret over his testimony claiming the
government had made things sound worse
than they were at the trial Holmes's
attorneys requested a new trial over the
new information if Holmes is not granted
a new trial she faces up to 20 years in
prison
still had on Law and crime daily a
Florida made his sentence after Trevor
Summers who was convicted of the
kidnapping and attempted murder of his
ex-wife but first we head to Connecticut
as jurors hear emotional testimony in
the Alex Jones definition trial